what's up guys i'm here testing out a
new huawei phone it's been announced in
april out in other countries right now
it's coming in singapore june 20th it is
the mate x s2 i do have it folded up
right now this is the lightest foldable
phone they're saying on the market right
now coming at 255 grams i've been
testing this out over the past few days
also the huawei gt3 pro watch which i
don't have on me right now i got to tell
you i'm impressed with what huawei is
doing with this device now i did try the
original mate x a couple years ago and
that was a really cool phone it folds
very differently the display folds
around the outside unlike the other
phones that they pulled on the inside
so
you wonder is it durable or is it not
durable huawei said this phone is a lot
more durable than the previous ones i
think 2.5 times durable than before and
i have not dropped it i'm not going to
drop it it's a 2600 singapore dollar
phone
but i'll trust huawei when they say it's
more durable all right let's talk about
specs inside of this we've got the
snapdragon triple a processor we've got
8 gigabytes of ram and 512 gigabytes of
onboard storage in this review unit now
in terms of the display size when it's
folded out it's 7.8 inches when you fold
it in half it's 6.5 inches and the
maximum resolution is 2480 by 2200 so we
got a pretty packed phone for the most
part now of course there are other specs
that are higher in specs for this model
which depending on where you're what
country you're in you may be able to
purchase that or not i'm not too sure
what it's going to be in singapore but
this is
pretty much part and parcel with other
flagship smartphones out there but it's
really the design of this phone that
gets you because it folds around as i
said before which is very unique and
only huawei has done this but this case
on the back of it does make it more
durable and more protected in that
regard because the back of the display
is covered and of course you've got
these sort of hinge covers here on the
side that's going to protect it if you
drop it it's nice if they add protection
versus you going out having to buy
another case for this and adding more
money because it's coming in around 2600
singapore dollars mind you when it
launches on the 20th of june
so battery size is around 4 800 plus
milliamp battery inside of this so this
will get you pretty much all day battery
depending on how you use the device now
for me i watch a lot of youtube videos
i'm on telegram whatsapp quite a bit
answering emails all those kind of
things and i'm getting much pretty much
full day usage out of this now of course
if i'm doing multimedia consumption that
will drain a little bit more but so far
i've been very happy with the battery
life out of this
and uh yeah it's pretty good i gotta
tell you the design on this is very very
nice and we gotta talk about the full
decrease inside the screen because this
is something that popped out to me as
soon as i took it out of the box is the
crease
is less prominent than what we've seen
on other foldable phones out there on
the market i know huawei's taking a lot
of pain and consideration to make it a
lot less so and you notice it right off
the bat so that's a big plus to huawei
in this regard but of course we've gotta
talk about the elephant in the room
right
apps
google services
can you use a huawei phone at 2022
without google services well
always app gallery has pulled out a lot
of things you have instagram available
to you facebook available to you there's
a lot of apps whatsapp et cetera et
cetera et cetera
there are uh software out there like g
space which sort of runs an emulator on
top of the os
to allow you to have google services now
i've tried it um there's a free version
which has a lot of ads
that kind of is a little bit buggy i
haven't tried the uh the paid version of
it but from other reviewers out there
they say it works well so that's an
option to look at but
most of the apps that i need are
available through the app gallery store
or from pedopixel or through other apk
websites out there so
i'm okay with that if you're wondering
about youtube
youtube vance is available as well that
water is kicking in hazaki yeah it is
right should we get out of here to
somewhere more quiet so as i was talking
about in terms of cameras your main
camera is going to be a 50 megapixel
camera this is a three camera setup on
the back of this as well
and
as i said it's
the images tend to be a little bit over
saturated and slightly overexposed now
of course you can adjust the
overexposure but the saturated aspect is
not something that you can adjust in
this camera system so and it's not the
display mind you because they've done a
really good job with the colors on this
this display which make it look very
natural so when i'm watching videos or
looking at photos it's that natural
color you can always obviously enhance
it if you want to but it's p3 color
gamut all that's inside of this but if
you're wondering if this is a leica
branded camera system and the answer is
no i think that partnership let's just
say that ship has sailed
so uh yeah but it's okay huawei still
makes really good cameras but this one
is just slightly more saturated than i
would prefer in terms of video quality
it's also really good the mics on this
are exceptional i will say this the
front-facing camera unlike other android
phones you can shoot up to 4k on it
but the front-facing camera is it's a
10-megapixel camera system
it's not as good as i was hoping it
would be this could be because of the
plastic screen protector that's on this
display all these foldable displays need
to have that screen protector for
durability that could impede the
resolution and the sharpness a little
bit because i noticed in 4k
my image looked a little bit muddy
especially when i'm doing selfies now
1080 of course probably primarily shoot
that anyway for instagram or for tick
tock so it's not a deal breaker but it's
something to take note of but on the
rear cameras video is sharp it is
beautiful and the mics on this thing
pick up your voice awesome is is really
really impressive um so yeah no issues
at all with that in that regard but what
is it like to use this phone as a camera
because it's full foldable it's actually
not that bad to be honest with you i
think the overall footprint of this
device feels like
most other smartphones out there let's
say that have a larger battery capacity
so it's uh they've done a good job
trying to keep it thin and trying to
keep it very easy um and that is the
size of it the width it all feels really
good when you want to take photos so if
you are into content creation and you're
worried about that do not be i had no
issues at all using that in that regard
the audio quality the speakers are
actually pretty good let's talk about
that for a second the speakers are good
but do not max out the volume because
there is a little distortion that comes
into play when you do that but if you
keep it about 90 of the max volume you
should be good it's clear it's loud very
easy to set that your phone down have a
conversation watch some youtube videos
or listen to podcasts while you're
cooking or
doing other things no issues at all with
that but uh just something to keep in
mind so anyway those are my thoughts on
the huawei mate xs2 now i'm just going
to show you real quickly what the huawei
gt3 pro their titanium watch looks like
because that's a pretty badass watch i
was really impressed i'll show you what
that looks like right now this video is
brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lab
chairs especially the all-new 2022 titan
evo with its revamped 4-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support if p
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely frost blue the titan evo is
even magnetized allowing the head pillow
to stick on the headrest without straps
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.com
alright guys taking a quick break from
being outside to talk to you about the
huawei watch gt pro titanium that's
right i've got it on my wrist right here
and i've been testing it out along with
the mate xs2
this watch
is impressive
nobody's paying me to say that i was
surprised to be honest with you i tried
a lot of different android based watches
this is harmony os but still kind of in
the same family and a lot of them are
pretty good but how do they compare to
the apple watch how do they compare to
the garmin fenix series well
this watch is right up there with them
it's titanium it does come at a premium
price though so be warned of that it
does come in a bracelet option leather
or flow laster or basically a rubber
strap but it does
pack one thing that i really appreciate
and that's good battery life up to two
weeks they're saying in eight days heavy
usage i can tell you i've been using
this for the past few days on the iphone
and on the mate xs2 and the battery is
impressive always on display will course
shorten the battery life but it is still
much better than a lot of other options
out there
uh in terms of some of the features that
stood out to me over 100 plus workouts
if you're a golfer you want to know your
golf swing speed your tempo your
backswing tempo you want to find out
these small things and usually you would
have to go to some sort of driving range
to find out this watch can help you do
that is it exactly accurate it's pretty
close to be honest with you it is pretty
close again do you like to wear a watch
when you golf or not that's up to you
but if you want something to give you
out some readouts this might be a watch
to consider also it has ecg in it it has
heart rate monitor skin temperature in
this regard
sp02 there's a lot of readings in this
watch a lot more than i will ever use to
be honest with you that's why i think it
kind of really more competes with the
garmin series than the apple watch at
this time if you want to compare smart
watches to smart watches thereabouts
because the apple watch is getting a lot
new features but there are some that
it's missing from their um
app gallery which is in this which is uh
i was quite shocked to be honest with
you usually i look at the apple watch as
the sort of staple for consumer products
of course garmin is a different level
altogether this kind of fits in between
the two
but i like how it wears it's a 46
millimeter as i said it is a little bit
larger but i like how it fits on the
wrist it is very easy to walk around
with it's lightweight it's not that
heavy it's titanium mind you
easy to charge fast charging you know
wireless charging as well
and yeah i'm really impressed with this
thing but i will say when you go into
the menu system when you tap on that
crown that you can turn
it is a very similar to the apple watch
huawei took some
inspiration from apple and you can see
it right away but you know what
look teach their own it doesn't bother
me whatsoever it's the functionality
it's the design and it's the performance
and i gotta say this watch is really
impressive and check this out you wanna
see something really cool talk about a
speaker on this thing
this is coming from the watch so you can
pause your music right there so if you
want to answer calls all that
this can be your speaker and i put on my
desk and i'm like
damn it's louder than some phones i've
tested so
it is impressive anyway those are my
thoughts on the gt3 pro titanium watch
now let's go back to my final thoughts
so as you saw from the watch very
impressive build quality is fantastic
right up there with apple love the
titanium it's solid great battery life
who doesn't enjoy a week's worth of
battery on a smart watch nowadays right
anyway uh absolutely love that also i
want to show you real quickly before we
go to my final thoughts on this what the
case looks like and how it does is it
covers the rear display here you see
this little button i'm going to show you
how this works so let's say you want to
fold the phone out right so you have to
unclip it here then you press this
button and that unlocks the rear of the
display you pull that out
and there you have it so you actually
have a little bit of a place where you
can hold your hand on the back of the
the phone with the case and it makes it
feel more secure as you're using it so
then you can browse the web or do
whatever you want to do and that works
great then if you just want to pull it
back up same thing hold it lock it
put the hinge cover on
and you are golden baby overall i'm very
impressed with this phone hallway's done
a fantastic job doing another foldable
phone on the market and i got to say um
it's the lightest out there it feels
really secure the display is fantastic
the power out of it's good google
services i think they're working around
that a little bit more now so it's not
as much of a deal breaker as it was a
couple years ago
and yeah if you're into a foldable
device and you want something a little
bit different out there
this might be a phone to consider anyway
those are my thoughts on the huawei mate
xs2 and the huawei gt3 pro watch let me
know your thoughts in the comments
section below are you looking to pick
this up any questions you have i'll try
to answer this for you like this video
subscribe to the channel hit that
notification bell as well because we
have more great videos coming your way
with that guys take care stay safe and
i'll chat you soon bye
[Music]
you